I'm always trying to look for what's the
connection between different artistic
forms and and what I do know is and I
know that it applies to what you do in
music uh is and also uh on your on your
talk show when it's time to go you just
go you know you look at all the
different things that you've been
through uh in your life and in this
recent in in your personal life recently
and people might say well how do you
keep going it's because you take it
moment to moment to moment I'm going to
take this and I'm going to write this
song then I'm going to write that song
I'm going to move to this moment then to
that moment well that's interesting you
said that because that's literally I
think everybody had a hard time doing
covid I I they tried to keep our show
going and what we did
um but like from my Ranch in Montana
which had very poor internet and like
could not be a more remote location in
the mountains and I'm tracing through
snow my marriage is falling apart no one
knows I'm just learning all these songs
I'm doing this other stuff for music
thing like it's like ever just is
hitting the fan and and and and all the
while you know you're like what's up
America and you know you're smiling and
you're you're I think I think a lot of
us have to do that whatever vocation you
choose like whatever your job is like I
think a lot of us have have to do that
sometimes but what I found helpful is
I would be like like truth like
completely bawling like right before we
would be shooting and be like how do I
fix this like you know and then we'd
start and we'd like let's say cover like
an hi story and some amazing human would
come on the screen and just say how
they're they went from something maybe
tragic and did something that usually
maybe people would find cheesy or
something but it's so healing and I
think when you step outside yourself and
not necessarily compartmentalize it but
but just let it go for a moment because
it seems so huge and then you focus on
someone else it kind of changes the
perspective on everything in your life
of course kind of it's healing in a
sense but it's hard to keep smiling
right there is at one time and I was
like you I never cancel I'm like I'm not
that person and I I was like I can't
actually fix this like I looked like oh
God put her in a jacket like I was like
it was real bad and I was really sad and
and so we had to like cancel um and I
know that's so rare for you because yeah
I've actually seen footage of you at
some award show and you're performing
your ass off and I know that I later
heard the backstory which is that you
needed to have an appendectomy didn't
they like and they like the doctor shows
are like the death for me you don't
understand like that happened yes like
my appendix was about to burst I
literally went into surgery hours later
something else happened the other time I
was doing it my first performance ever
on the Grammys this is a real story I
was called right as I was leaving for
the Grammys being picked up by my
publicist at the time Roger wanowski and
was told I had cancerous results
and I was like and cancer like runs in
our family like ovarian cervical like
just the gamut breasts everything and I
was like what and I and and the whole
day was ruined because I just couldn't
stop crying because I was like wait I
haven't done so much like
in my life I was like and it just was
the worst day ever
true story
the next morning I called back to
schedule because I was like I can't they
they're like we need you to come in now
it's like well I I'm gonna be performing
on the Grammys so and it was like a huge
moment for any kid that grows up watch
it that's like the epic thing for you
and and literally called the next
morning for like what I needed to do
next and they were like oh we're so
sorry those were actually someone else's
results
I was like you no first of all my first
thought was like who did you tell they
were fine right and now you're calling
them and telling them they have cancer
like I'm like wait what and and and and
then they called Clark kellyson and then
I was like
we're so sorry Clark you know whether
you're on a cross-country drive or on
your daily commute time in the car is
perfect for listening to podcasts like I
don't know this one
T-Mobile covers more highway miles with
5G than anyone their Network helps keep
you connected to all your favorite
podcasts when you're out and about I
gotta tell you I like to road trip
sometimes I do too and I I have T-Mobile
and I I can honestly say there's
coverage that's important like there's
been times in my life where I'm out on
the road driving around and uh
especially on those family trips you're
out in the desert you want to make sure
you have that coverage yeah what if you
get like your car breaks down and you're
just there sitting there like a chump
yeah with no coverage yeah not this guy
I've got T-Mobile got 5G find out more
at t-mobile.com Cy that's s e e w h y
for me they're like like sometimes I
don't want to go because I'm like what
the hell is gonna happen to me like
because something always happens I feel
like and and I won that night oh my God
and then I won again and then I just
kept crying because I was like God's
giving me this book foreign
was like oh my gosh your performance is
because it's an emotional song in
general they were like it was so
beautiful and I was like that's because
I was dying and I was like so worried
and they had to redo my makeup three
times I'm like you people ruined an
entire moment to like for me and I just
I yeah I award shows in general like
always happens to me I don't know
I'm always afraid to say yes like
because who knows what's gonna happen my
favorite uh my award show moment was I
was working well there's a bunch of
crazy things that have happened but I
was working on an award show once and
I'm seeing it and had to do kind of like
a song and dance number and I can sort
of like hold a tune if necessary in a
comedic way so it was all fine but then
it was important that I hit this note at
the end yeah and so they said you know
about this but they said what we're
gonna do is we're gonna get you into the
Capitol Records building there's the
orchestra is there that's gonna be did
you do it while they were playing and
yeah it was it was the greatest thing
and what they did is they had me hit
this sing it there so they had it on
this track yeah but then they had me hit
this one note so I was gonna sing it
live but then at the end go so welcome
to the you know I gotta hit this note up
there and hold it which I don't do uh
you've been piece of cake for you but I
don't do that so they they auto-tuned it
and then they uh they did this thing
where they extend it for a long time so
it looks like I'm really holding the
note oh yeah and they said so Conan just
get to that part and then get to there
and then go and get down on one knee and
mime it and we'll we'll slide it across
and look like you hit it okay so I do
the whole bid I do all the jokes then I
go into the song then I hit the note and
the crowd you know was really liked it
and they were like yeah and I walk off
stage and Barry Manilow is standing
there and he's looking at me and he says
hey man you hit that note and held it
and I said auto-tune pre-record he went
oh and walked away
like I had farted you know
and then his face felt like he'd had a
stroke
and he just turned and walked away and
I'm like yeah he was just like oh you
sick in me yeah it was a fun moment for
me